Shure: 那个呢那应该也差不多吧
Shure: That one should be almost done too, right?
Jake:呀呀
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Lucia: 好玩吗
Lucia: Is it fun?
Tasha: 然后再挤下来
Tasha: And then squeeze it down
Tasha: 就像蛋糕周围
Tasha: Just like around a cake
Jake:就是我要把这个都给填上
Jake: I need to fill all of this
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right
Shure: 哦我可以用吉他弹这首歌
Shure: Oh, I can play this song on guitar
Shure: 我可以用吉他弹这首歌
Shure: I can play this song on guitar
Tasha: 哎你看你应该把它转一圈来的
Tasha: Hey, look, you should have spun it around
Katrina: 这个大羊排
Katrina: This big lamb chop
Katrina: 这今天要做吗
Katrina: Are we making this today?
Shure: 加一块然后你再那什么告五伦
Shure: Add a piece and then you do whatever with it
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:来了
Jake: Coming
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈都在吃
Jake: Hahaha, everyone's eating
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Shure: 你再拿一块
Shure: Take another piece
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈等饿了谁敢吃啊
Lucia: Haha, who's brave enough to eat when they're hungry
Shure: 然后我再给他们送过去
Shure: Then I'll send it to them
Tasha: 不是谁敢吃啊
Tasha: Who's brave enough to eat it
Jake:哈哈哈不要靠你了
Jake: Hahaha, don't count on you
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Katrina: 这是什么肉
Katrina: What kind of meat is this?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Katrina: 这是羊排吗
Katrina: Is this lamb ribs?
Jake:来吧哈哈哈哈
Jake: Come on, hahaha
Lucia: 来吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Come on, hahaha
Lucia: 西亚真傻
Lucia: Sia, you're so silly
Shure: 那是猪的排骨
Shure: Those are pork ribs.
Tasha: 救命啊
Tasha: Help!
Lucia: 我来我你来你来你来
Lucia: I'll do it, you do it, you do it
Jake:我来哈哈
Jake: I'll do it, haha
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Jake:你来你来
Jake: You do it
Katrina: 粗的是吗
Katrina: Is it thick?
Jake:你来我来我来
Jake: You do it, I'll do it, I'll do it
Lucia: 等一下我先给你稍微整理一下啊
Lucia: Wait, let me tidy it up a bit for you
Jake:好玩吗好玩好
Jake: Is it fun? It's fun
Katrina: 猪
Katrina: Pork
Lucia: 不过
Lucia: But
Lucia: 我觉得我可能跟你没法整理的很平坦
Lucia: I don't think I can make it very flat for you
Jake:玩
Jake: Play
Katrina: 这是骨头耶
Katrina: This is a bone
Lucia: 剩下的就要靠您自己了
Lucia: The rest is up to you
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 刮腻了是吗
Shure: Are you tired of scraping?
Katrina: 鸡翅确实难烤熟再换
Katrina: Chicken wings are indeed hard to cook, let's switch
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Lucia: 就是挤完之后给他上面这弄平了
Lucia: Just smooth it out after squeezing it
Katrina: 一个
Katrina: One
Lucia: 这一会要弄不平
Lucia: It's hard to make it flat
Lucia: 您呢自己弄弄哈
Lucia: You handle it yourself
Alice:放冰箱也没事
Alice: It's okay to put it in the fridge
Jake:我试试我试一下我看有多深哈哈哈
Jake: Let me try, let me see how deep it is, hahaha
Alice:有的就专门
Alice: Some people do that
Katrina: 提前一天研
Katrina: Prepare a day in advance
Alice:嗯放冰箱
Alice: Yeah, put it in the fridge
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 咱这好奇心用在合适的地方吧
Lucia: Let's use our curiosity in the right place
Katrina: 有你
Katrina: You have it
Shure: 鸡
Shure: Chicken
Jake:好的好的好的好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay, alright
Jake:我来了来了
Jake: I'm here, I'm here.
Tasha: 我已经迫不及待了
Tasha: I can't wait any longer.
Lucia: 哈哈还是得有经验的
Lucia: Haha, experience really does matter.
Shure: 他也有肩膀吧
Shure: He has shoulders too, right?
Alice:温暖的时刻
Alice: Warm moments.
Shure: 跟鸭子应该差不多吧
Shure: Should be similar to a duck, right?
Katrina: 时刻清楚洞悉你的不坚定
Katrina: Always clearly aware of your hesitation.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 票子是不是就像一个蛋糕了哈哈
Tasha: Tickets are kind of like a cake, haha.
Lucia: 这让我想到那个
Lucia: This reminds me of...
Lucia: 就是哈利波特里面
Lucia: You know, from Harry Potter.
Shure: 这些都能弹着唱
Shure: You can sing and play all these.
Lucia: 海格给哈利做那个蛋糕
Lucia: Hagrid made that cake for Harry.
小薇 ：哦前段时间回来好利来卖那个
Tasha: Oh, recently back at Holiland, they sold that.
Lucia: 对对对是的
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 就是第一次做蛋糕的人
Lucia: It's like the first time making a cake.
Lucia: 做出来的蛋糕差不多就长那样
Lucia: The cake pretty much looked like that.
Lucia: 我现在相信了
Lucia: Now I believe it.
Shure: 等烤一会
Shure: Let it bake for a while.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 明白你
Katrina: I understand you.
Lucia: i'm totally convinced now
Lucia: I'm totally convinced now.
Katrina: 这个你说这个叫什么来着
Katrina: What do you call this again?
Shure: 排骨
Shure: Ribs.
Katrina: 排骨
Katrina: Ribs.
Shure: 排骨认识吗
Shure: You know ribs?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 猪身上的排骨吗
Katrina: Ribs from a pig, right?
Jake:差不多啊
Jake: Pretty much, yeah.
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: It's all good.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 不太认识
Katrina: Not really familiar.
Lucia: 整挺好整挺好
Lucia: It's all good, it's all good.
Jake:整挺好我再整整
Jake: It's all good, I'll fix it.
Jake:我真想知道他有多高
Jake: I really want to know how tall he is.
Lucia: 不是吧
Lucia: No way.
Alice:啊啊
Alice: Ah, ah.
Jake:我刚刚好歹要这个东西我没整
Jake: I just wanted this thing, but I didn't fix it.
Lucia: 啊那你们现在几点
Lucia: Ah, what time is it for you guys now?
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Katrina: one two three four
Katrina: One two three four
Jake:色泽水深
Jake: Water depth color
Lucia: 测点水深
Lucia: Measure the water depth
Lucia: 水深2.二点几
Lucia: Water depth is about 2. something
Katrina: 春风十里
Katrina: Spring breeze ten miles
Shure: 真的希望你
Shure: Really hope you
Lucia: 马克图的那个2.5英尺
Lucia: Marked that it's 2.5 feet
Katrina: 不只是
Katrina: Not just
Shure: 合理的吧
Shure: Reasonable, right?
Lucia: 我们已经毫来毫不在意
Lucia: We don't care anymore
Jake:哈哈哈很好吃
Jake: Hahaha it's really delicious
Lucia: 哈哈哈很好吃吗
Lucia: Hahaha is it really delicious?
Alice:感觉这火不旺
Alice: Feels like the fire isn't strong
Jake:吗啊吃一个
Jake: Come on, have one
Lucia: 啊吃一个
Lucia: Ah, have one
Alice:炭要碎掉了
Alice: The charcoal is about to break
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 你冷静一点
Lucia: Calm down
Shure: 我带你去梦的水星
Shure: I'll take you to the dream's water planet
Katrina: 一起
Katrina: Together
Shure: 慢慢地流动
Shure: Flow slowly
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 没让我爱你
Katrina: Didn't make me love you
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: It's okay, just looking at you
Shure: 你为什么是转着的
Shure: Why are you spinning?
Lucia: 先看这水深
Lucia: Check the water depth first
Lucia: 没有2.5英尺
Lucia: It's not 2.5 feet
Shure: 嗯你们用的是iPad是吗
Shure: Hmm, you guys are using an iPad, right?
Lucia: 哇有点像蛋糕啊
Lucia: Wow, it looks like a cake
Lucia: 说实话不像汉堡
Lucia: Honestly, it doesn't look like a burger
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, it's okay
Jake:谢谢鼓励
Jake: Thanks for the encouragement
Shure: 给你看看
Shure: Let me show you
Lucia: 杨老师这技术可以嗯
Lucia: Jake, your skill is good, huh
Lucia: 哈哈不是这个有点丑吧
Lucia: Haha, isn't this a bit ugly?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly
Alice:好香啊好熏啊
Alice: It smells so good, but it's so smoky.
Shure: 中看有点不中吃
Shure: Looks good, but not so tasty.
Lucia: 叫什么叫碗大厦于江青哈哈哈
Lucia: What are you calling it, a bowl big as a building? Haha
Shure: 好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, haha.
Shure: 就是那些调料跟我妈那个放的都一样
Shure: The seasoning is the same as my mom's.
Shure: 但是就完全不一个味
Shure: But it tastes completely different.
Jake:挽回作为蛋糕的尊严
Jake: Restore the dignity of the cake.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 还行这最起码就是挺还还算挺好吃
Shure: It's alright, at least it's quite tasty.
Katrina: 为什么不能洒在肉上
Katrina: Why can't we sprinkle it on the meat?
Jake:主要问题是不是我多多的要存了
Jake: The main problem is, should I save more?
Lucia: 主要问题是不是我多做呀
Lucia: The main problem is, did I make too much?
Shure: 但是就是跟我妈那个味完全不一样
Shure: But it tastes completely different from my mom's.
Alice:主要是让那个水掉下去
Alice: The main thing is to let the water drip off.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:我觉得也是
Jake: I think so too.
Shure: 也不能说完全吧完全有点离谱
Shure: Can't say completely, that's a bit much.
Jake:嗯就不太够
Jake: Yeah, it's not quite enough.
Katrina: 看看啊试验一下
Katrina: Let's see, let's test it out.
Shure: 就是感觉什么什么比例都不对
Shure: Feels like the proportions are all wrong.
Jake:建材不够
Jake: Not enough materials.
Jake:就外边的漆就不刷了吧就是
Jake: Let's not paint the outer layer then.
Shure: 这不等你回去吃去吗
Shure: Isn't this for you to take home and eat?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 别别到时候我妈一紧张
Shure: Don't, my mom will get nervous.
Jake:好怎么拯救
Jake: How do we save it?
Shure: 然后也也放不明白了
Shure: Then she won't know how to put it.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 你刮好了吗
Lucia: Have you finished scraping?
Jake:我可以没有刮好对吗
Jake: Can I say I haven't finished scraping?
Lucia: 好那就已经刮好
Lucia: Okay, then it's done.
Lucia: 然后开始在外形上拯救
Lucia: Let's start saving the appearance.
Jake:怎么拯救
Jake: How do we save it?
Lucia: 首先搞颜色
Lucia: First, fix the color.
Lucia: 然后搞蛋糕哦
Lucia: Then fix the cake.
Shure: 哪个啊那个小群
Shure: Which one? The small group?
Shure: 查物那个群啊
Shure: The group for checking stuff?
Shure: 几何几何几何几何
Shure: Geometric, geometric, geometric.
Shure: 他不是今年上半年结婚了吗
Shure: Didn't he get married earlier this year?
Lucia: 我再出去喝两口壮壮胆
Lucia: I'll go out and have a few more drinks for courage.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后说他带对象第一次回家的时候
Shure: So, he said the first time he brought his girlfriend home...
Shure: 然后说哎呀他他妈妈一点不紧张
Shure: He said his mom wasn't nervous at all.
Shure: 聊着聊着天突然说不行
Shure: They were chatting, and suddenly she said, "Oh no!"
Shure: 锅在火上快糊了
Shure: "The pot on the stove is about to burn!"
Lucia: 这些杯子是随便哪一个用都行的
Lucia: You can use any of these cups.
Shure: 然后跑去厨房
Shure: Then she ran to the kitchen.
Jake:还行啊
Jake: Not bad.
Shure: 哈哈哈那行
Shure: Hahaha, that works.
Katrina: 有一个是我的
Katrina: One of these is mine.
Jake:还行我也觉得还行
Jake: Not bad, I think it's okay too.
Jake:好玩吗好玩
Jake: Is it fun? It's fun.
Shure: 说明已经只剩
Shure: That means there's only...
Lucia: 哪一个呀
Lucia: Which one?
Tasha: 哈哈做蛋糕其实还挺好玩的吧
Tasha: Haha, making cakes is actually quite fun.
Shure: 只剩这一个线程能工作了
Shure: 知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:确实确实好玩
Jake: Indeed, it is fun.
Shure: 什么意思
Shure: What do you mean?
Shure: 就是脑袋里面全只想这一件事了
Shure: It's like, only thinking about this one thing.
Lucia: 喝上口再进去弄那个蛋糕
Lucia: Take a sip and then go back to working on the cake.
Jake:嗯好玩
Jake: Yeah, it's fun.
Shure: 就是跟你搜手
Shure: It's like playing games with you.
Katrina: 蛋糕做到哪一步了
Katrina: How far along is the cake?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 现在用刮刀刮上了奶油
Lucia: Now we're spreading the cream with a spatula.
Lucia: 要进去看一眼吗
Lucia: Do you want to take a look?
Katrina: 看
Katrina: Sure.
Jake:干嘛往往往里边哎
Jake: What are you doing, going inside?
Shure: 嗯你在喝什么
Shure: Hmm, what are you drinking?
Lucia: 杨老板在刮
Lucia: Jake is spreading the cream.
Jake:那天你不是玩过吗
Jake: Didn't you play with it that day?
Lucia: 我觉得挺不错的
Lucia: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:对啊好
Jake: Yeah, it's good.
Lucia: 本来是我刮来着
Lucia: I was originally spreading it.
Jake:要玩好要玩
Jake: If you want to play, play well.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow.
Lucia: 但是他这个
Lucia: But he's really skilled.
Lucia: 呵呵水平非常高超
Lucia: Haha, his level is really high.
Shure: 就让你自己更虚一点是吧
Shure: So it makes you feel a bit more humbled, right?
Katrina: 看听说你的水平很高超
Katrina: I heard you're really skilled.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How's it going?
Jake:是像吗哈哈
Jake: Does it look like it? Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈像
Katrina: Haha, it does!
Lucia: 像不像那个
Lucia: Doesn't it look like that?
Shure: 所以边烤着就边吃了
Shure: So you're grilling and eating at the same time.
Lucia: 就是哈利波特里面
Lucia: Just like in Harry Potter.
Katrina: 嗯哈利波特
Katrina: Yeah, Harry Potter.
Lucia: 海格给哈利做的那个蛋糕
Lucia: The cake Hagrid made for Harry.
Katrina: 对啊对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Shure: 反正菜也好像买少了
Shure: Seems like we didn't buy enough food.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 你看你看你看
Shure: Look, look, look.
Shure: 就这么点啊
Shure: Just this much?
Shure: 对他就是那个那个那个那个
Shure: Yep, it's like that, that, that...
Jake:就照着那个做的就好了吗好了
Jake: Just follow that and it'll be good, okay?
Shure: 腌的还不少啊
Shure: We marinated quite a lot.
Shure: 腌的确实不少
Shure: Really a lot.
Shure: 但是效率很低
Shure: But the efficiency is low.
Lucia: 巧克力粉吗
Lucia: Is it chocolate powder?
Shure: 就是他你看这边都是空的
Shure: Look, this part is empty.
Jake:画龙点睛画蛇点睛
Jake: Adding the finishing touches.
Shure: 没腌好是吧
Shure: Didn't marinate well, right?
Lucia: 到底想说什么
Lucia: What are you trying to say?
Shure: 就是他的碳只有一半
Shure: His charcoal is only half.
Jake:就就牛逼牛逼好哈
Jake: Just awesome, awesome, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈这这这俩
Lucia: Haha, these two words.
Lucia: 这俩词完全是不同的意思啊
Lucia: They mean completely different things!
Shure: 油还不够是吗
Shure: Not enough oil, right?
Lucia: 你可考虑好
Lucia: Think it over.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Alice:不是我就想让他滴下去
Alice: No, I just want it to drip down.
Shure: 哦懂了
Shure: Oh, got it.
Alice:我嫌火太不旺了
Alice: I think the fire is too weak.
Shure: 嘿嘿
Shure: Hehe.
Shure: 带你看我们的小院吧
Shure: Let me show you our yard.
Shure: 然后刚刚弄俩补光灯
Shure: And just added two fill lights.
Shure: 人呢怎么就你们两个了
Shure: Where is everyone? Why is it just you two?
Shure: 嗯在屋里吃的
Shure: Hmm, they're eating inside.
Lucia: 神来之笔
Lucia: It's a stroke of genius.
Shure: 不他们在屋里做蛋糕呢
Shure: No, they're making cakes inside.
Shure: 哈哈就是这几个
Shure: Haha, it's just these few.
Jake:哇
Jake: Wow.
Shure: 就是这就是为给AI这个数据集就是
Shure: This is for the AI dataset.
Shure: 人类在探索一些食物
Shure: Humans are exploring some food.
Shure: 能不能吃的这种感觉你知道吗
Shure: To see if it's edible, you know?
Katrina: 嗯拍照
Katrina: Hmm, take a photo.
Lucia: 拍照拍照
Lucia: Take a photo, take a photo.
Shure: 如何把一坨看着还能吃的东西
Shure: How to turn something that looks edible
Shure: 就弄得不能吃了对
Shure: Into something inedible, right?
Shure: 带你看看室内
Shure: Let me show you inside.
Shure: 这个是我们的leather
Shure: This is our leather.
Shure: 给他一个特写吧
Shure: Give it a close-up shot.
Shure: 杨老板回个头
Shure: Jake, turn around.
Alice:我想直接爆炒了
Alice: I want to stir-fry it directly.
Alice:家人说实话
Alice: Honestly, family.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 很棒
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 这是我的室友们
Shure: These are my roommates.
Shure: 这是我的被美女包围的室友们
Shure: These are my roommates surrounded by beautiful ladies.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 掉了掉
Katrina: It fell, it fell.
Shure: 然后这个就是
Shure: And this is...
Katrina: 滑下来了怎么了
Katrina: It slid down, what's up?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好我来拯救他
Jake: Okay, I'll save it.
Shure: 没有这是从那个泽浩那投的
Shure: No, this was sent over by Zehao.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 我是不是举高点会显得我脸短一点
Shure: Would raising it higher make my face look shorter?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 那我露半张脸
Shure: Then I'll show half my face.
Shure: 我这样哈哈哈
Shure: Like this, hahaha.
Shure: 讨厌
Shure: Annoying.
Shure: 嗯好好好
Shure: Hmm, okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 然后这个这个这就是我们小院
Shure: And this, this is our courtyard.
Shure: 差不多是这个样子
Shure: It looks like this.
Shure: 然后还有个二楼
Shure: And there's a second floor.
Shure: 二楼的构造跟这个差不多
Shure: The second floor layout is similar to this.
Jake:我也觉得行
Jake: I think it's good too.
Shure: 然后厕所什么就不不给您看了
Shure: And the bathroom, we won't show you that.
Lucia: 行行
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Shure: 然后刚刚卡了一瓶起泡酒
Shure: And just now, I opened a bottle of sparkling wine.
Katrina: 我在做蛋糕呢
Katrina: I'm making a cake.
Shure: 起泡酒
Shure: Sparkling wine.
Shure: 然后就是开的过程特别的狼狈
Shure: And the opening process was really messy.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure: 就他一直一瓶
Shure: It was just one bottle.
Shure: 不够你们几个喝吗
Shure: Not enough for you all, right?
Shure: 那一瓶才多少
Shure: How much was in that bottle?
Shure: 倒了四五杯
Shure: Poured four or five glasses.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep.
Shure: 好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 送里面去吧
Shure: Take it inside.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 这个是能
Shure: This is...
Shure: 但是我跟你讲
Shure: But let me tell you,
Shure: 这个玉制的它还没有我腌的好吃
Shure: This jade one isn't as tasty as the one I pickled.
Katrina: 好想啊
Katrina: I really want to try it.
Katrina: 当当当当
Katrina: Ta-da!
Katrina: 给个特写
Katrina: Give it a close-up.
Shure: 好大
Shure: It's huge.
Lucia: 切吧
Lucia: Cut it.
Shure: 给你看看作者
Shure: Let me show you the creator.
Lucia: 做一个
Lucia: Make one.
Tasha: 你可以用这个切
Tasha: You can cut it with this.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Shure: 切切切这历史性的一刀吧
Shure: Make the historic cut.
Jake:怎么切切
Jake: How should I cut it?
Tasha: 随便你啊
Tasha: However you like.
Tasha: 你想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: Cut it however you want.
Shure: 你看5个就不好切
Shure: See, it's hard to cut into five pieces.
Shure: 这这时候就就可以问AI一个问题
Shure: This is the time to ask AI a question.
Shure: 我们放几个他更好切一些
Shure: How many pieces should we cut it into to make it easier?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 好吵啊好吵
Shure: It's so noisy, so noisy.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈哈怎么能嫌弃我呢
Shure: How can you dislike me?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎后面这个小心
Lucia: Hey, be careful with the one behind you.
Shure: 你一天说的话够我一个星期说的话了
Shure: You talk more in one day than I do in a week.
Shure: 留点面子留点面子
Shure: Save me some face, save me some face.
Shure: 免提呢免提呢
Shure: Speakerphone, speakerphone.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 来来来杨老板吃串
Shure: Come on, Jake, have a skewer.
Jake:好没手了
Jake: Okay, but my hands are full.
Jake:没关系好谢谢你
Jake: It's okay, thank you.
Jake:不敢下手
Jake: I'm afraid to start.
Shure: 历史性的一刀
Shure: A historic cut.
Shure: 哎呀妈呀
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀哈哈
Lucia: Oh my gosh, haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 好像没给这盘子剁碎了然后把
Shure: It looks like I didn't chop this plate to pieces.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈快刀斩乱麻
Lucia: Haha, cut the knot quickly.
Shure: 哎呀我天呐
Shure: Oh my, oh my.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Lucia: 哈哈哈卧槽爆浆了
Lucia: Hahaha, it burst out.
Shure: 所以你在干什么
Shure: So what are you doing?
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 你在看电影吗
Shure: Are you watching a movie?
Alice:what do you see
Alice: What do you see?
Shure: 对我在看电影哦好的
Shure: Yes, I'm watching a movie. Oh, okay.
Katrina: 高楼大厦崩塌了
Katrina: The skyscraper is collapsing.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
Katrina: 紧急维修
Katrina: Emergency repair.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈紧急维修
Katrina: Hahaha, emergency repair.
Shure: 你是上铺还是下铺呀上铺
Shure: Are you on the top bunk or the bottom bunk?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Katrina: 紧急公关
Katrina: Emergency PR.
Shure: 嗯那你现在是坐在
Shure: Hmm, so you're sitting.
Shure: 底下
Shure: Below.
Jake:大楼要导致去拿胶带糊
Jake: The building needs some tape to patch it up.
Shure: 我现在坐在床上啊
Shure: I'm sitting on the bed right now.
Shure: 行挺好
Shure: Alright, sounds good.
Jake:我要不先切吧
Jake: Should I start cutting first?
Katrina: 那我先今天晚上回来
Katrina: I'll be back tonight then.
Shure: 我靠我靠我靠我靠
Shure: Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Lucia: 也行切了再放草莓吧
Lucia: Yeah, cut it and then add the strawberries.
Shure: 好像给补光灯绊倒了
Shure: Seems like I tripped over the light.
Jake:对我这个也抵一下
Jake: Yeah, hold this for me too.
Shure: 这就是我每天拿着300块钱的生活
Shure: This is my life with 300 bucks a day.
Shure: 哈哈哈捣乱是吧
Shure: Hahaha, you're causing trouble, huh?
Shure: 没有怎么捣乱了呢
Shure: Not really, how am I causing trouble?
Tasha: 他已经完全失去人们的样子了
Tasha: He totally lost his mind already.
Shure: 我就是捣乱
Shure: I'm just messing around.
Jake:有好的有好的
Jake: There are good ones, there are good ones.
Shure: 我是给AI贡献伟大数据集的
Shure: I'm contributing great data sets for AI.
Jake:虽然不多
Jake: Even though it's not much.
Lucia: 最后一块是好的
Lucia: The last piece is good.
Shure: 就是让他看一个
Shure: Just let him see one.
Shure: 不是所以
Shure: No, so...
Shure: 所以
Shure: So...
Shure: 现在你那个你训练出来的AI看你
Shure: Now the AI you trained is watching you.
Shure: 就跟你看我玩人类一败涂地一样
Shure: It's like you watching me play "Human Fall Flat."
Jake:你现在这个样子像不像那什么
Jake: Do you look like that thing now?
Shure: 真的吗我
Shure: Really, do I?
Shure: 我有那么离谱吗
Shure: Am I that ridiculous?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 路路华福
Lucia: Lulu Wafers.
Shure: 有你那个绝对就已经不是人类范畴
Shure: If you reach that level, you're no longer human.
Lucia: 可丽饼
Lucia: Crepes.
Jake:可以是吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Shure: 能做到了
Shure: I can do it.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 为什么不是
Shure: Why not?
Lucia: 对有点像
Lucia: Yeah, kind of.
Shure: 当然可以
Shure: Of course.
Jake:我先放那先放这
Jake: I'll put this here first.
Shure: 就是那两个手都不能同步那种
Shure: It's like both hands can't sync.
Shure: 谁两个手不能同步
Shure: Whose hands can't sync?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 嗯你
Shure: Hmm, you
Lucia: 哎我觉得这个pink Champagne挺好喝的
Lucia: Hey, I think this pink Champagne is pretty good.
Shure: 你还好意思问
Shure: You still have the nerve to ask.
Lucia: 甜度很高我喜欢
Lucia: It's very sweet, I like it.
Shure: 反正不是我
Shure: Well, it's not me.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright
Shure: 没事了问候一下看看你
Shure: It's okay, just checking in on you.
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe
Shure: 啊哈哈哈哦
Shure: Ahahaha oh
Shure: 你用iPad
Shure: You're using an iPad
Shure: 就是一整张屏幕都是我这张嘴是吧
Shure: So the whole screen is just my mouth, right?
Shure: 所以有何感想
Shure: So what do you think?
Shure: 嗓子发炎了吗
Shure: Throat inflamed?
Shure: 什么不能
Shure: What can't
Shure: 不现在不敢说话骂我
Shure: Not daring to speak and curse me now?
Jake:多少有点丑
Jake: It's a bit ugly
Shure: 只能比手势骂我是吗
Shure: Can only use gestures to curse me, right?
Jake:哇好有那种高级料理的感觉
Jake: Wow, it has that high-end cuisine feel.
Lucia: 哇好有这种高级料理的哈哈
Lucia: Wow, it really has that high-end cuisine feel, haha.
Shure: 啊啊哈哈哈
Shure: Ahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:不会夸就硬夸
Jake: If you can't compliment, just force it.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 好了好了不跟你唠了我去接着考去了
Shure: Alright, alright, I'm done talking, I'm going back to study.
Jake:这个倒还行哎
Jake: This one is actually okay.
Tasha: 这个还行
Tasha: This one is okay.
Tasha: 你要放在一起吗
Tasha: Are you going to put it together?
Tasha: 就给一个人吃
Tasha: Just for one person to eat?
Jake:好再来一个
Jake: Alright, one more.
Shure: 拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye
Shure: 你看什么电影呢
Shure: What movie are you watching?
Lucia: 咱这盘还够吗
Lucia: Is this plate enough?
Jake: 哎杨老板灯关一下
Jake: Hey, Jake, turn off the light.
Shure: 叫什么来着
Shure: What's it called again?
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man
Shure: 名字好长啊
Shure: The name is so long.
Shure: 看半天了
Shure: Been watching for a while.
Shure: 名没记住是吧
Shure: Still didn't remember the name, right?
Lucia: 好这份提拉米苏你去做吧哈哈
Lucia: Okay, you go make this tiramisu, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哪哪个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 没事这个做的很好
Lucia: No worries, this one is made really well.
Alice:都可以
Alice: Either one is fine.
Shure: 听着就像我没看过的电影
Shure: Sounds like a movie I haven't seen.
Jake:好这个还行
Jake: Okay, this one's alright.
Katrina: 都可以
Katrina: Either one is fine.
Lucia: 嗯好看
Lucia: Hmm, looks good.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 回头补补
Shure: I'll catch up later.
Tasha: 就是那种这么大一个坎
Tasha: It's like there's this huge hurdle.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 然后里面就一个小姐
Tasha: And inside there's just one lady.
Shure: 拜
Shure: Bye.
Lucia: 哈哈哎
Lucia: Haha, oh.
Jake:对对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 对对对确实很高级
Lucia: Yes, it really is quite classy.
Shure: 拜
Shure: Bye.
Shure: 那我挂着
Shure: I'm hanging up.
Lucia: 我咋觉得咱这盘子
Lucia: Why do I feel like our plate...
Shure: 哎呦怎么了
Shure: Oh no, what happened?
Lucia: 要不我上楼看看
Lucia: Should I go upstairs and check?
Shure: 好好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 我挂着我挂着
Shure: I'm hanging up, I'm hanging up.
Shure: 我给他支着
Shure: I'll hold it for him.
Shure: 好吧不然话一直举着很累的
Shure: Alright, otherwise holding it up the whole time is tiring.
Jake:唯一的拿得出手的东西
Jake: The only thing worth showing off.
Shure: 哎我啤酒呢
Shure: Hey, where's my beer?
Tasha: 无一例外
Tasha: No exceptions.
Katrina: 耶耶
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 不是因为你身体好
Shure: It's not because you're healthy.
Shure: 是因为我没得喝哈哈哈
Shure: It's because I don't have anything to drink, haha.
Shure: 我这有酒但是我这连气泡水都没有了
Shure: I have alcohol, but I don't even have sparkling water.
Shure: 然后他如果单加椰子汁
Shure: And if he adds just coconut water...
Shure: 或者单加牛奶的话
Shure: Or just milk...
Shure: 会很难喝
Shure: It will taste terrible.
Shure: 因为有蛋白质
Shure: Because there's protein.
Shure: 他会有絮状物
Shure: It will have clumps.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 啊我还没尝尝那起泡酒什么味
Shure: Ah, I haven't tried that sparkling wine yet.
Shure: 来瓶
Shure: Bring a bottle.
Shure: 起泡酒尝尝吗
Shure: Want to try some sparkling wine?
Shure: 你在跟我说话吗
Shure: Are you talking to me?
Shure: 嗯我又没得喝
Shure: Hmm, I don't have anything to drink.
Shure: 你跟我说什么话
Shure: What are you talking to me about?
Lucia: all the kicks and all the lines you see fire in their eyes
Lucia: All the kicks and all the lines you see fire in their eyes.
Katrina: 喔喔喔喔喔喔喔喔喔喔喔
Katrina: Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh.
Shure: 可以换着喝
Shure: We can switch drinks.
Shure: 嗯真好喝
Shure: Hmm, really tasty.
Lucia: now she's stronger than you know
Lucia: Now she's stronger than you know.
Lucia: 啊我又拿了几个盘子
Lucia: Ah, I grabbed a few more plates.
Lucia: 稍等冲一下哈
Lucia: Hold on, let me rinse them.
Shure: 全是腿这么委屈呢
Shure: All legs, so unfair.
Lucia: 哎呀咦咦咦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh!
Jake:切蛋糕一般怎么切啊谢谢您
Jake: How do you usually cut a cake? Thank you.
Shure: 天呐
Shure: Oh my god.
Tasha: 哇这一般就是高级料理的样子
Tasha: Wow, this looks like high-end cuisine.
Shure: 怎么了又
Shure: What happened now?
Shure: 没事瞅瞅你
Shure: Nothing, just looking at you.
Shure: 但是我要要要
Shure: But I want to...
Shure: 正面看你才能看出你是正的
Shure: Only when I look at you head-on can I see you're straight.
Jake:哎呀这东西不能放
Jake: Oh no, this can't be left out.
Shure: 你把你的手机横过来嘛
Shure: Turn your phone horizontally.
Shure: 那我不就反了吗
Shure: Then wouldn't I be upside down?
Shure: 不会啊
Shure: No, you wouldn't.
Jake:还有一个串是吧
Jake: There's another skewer, right?
Shure: 我这边他会根据你那边调的是吗
Shure: Over here, will it adjust based on your side?
Shure: 嗯你现在是
Shure: Hmm, now you're...
Shure: 我现在是横着的
Shure: Now I'm horizontal.
Jake:把成品做成的原材料感觉
Jake: Feels like turning a finished product back into raw materials.
Jake:哈哈哈把成品做成的原材料
Jake: Hahaha, turning a finished product back into raw materials.
Shure: 哦但是有一半脸没有了是吗
Shure: Oh, but half of my face is missing, right?
Lucia: 怎怎么了
Lucia: What happened?
Jake:哈哈哈就是
Jake: Hahaha, exactly.
Lucia: 哈哈哈您怎么想到的
Lucia: Hahaha, how did you come up with that?
Shure: 没有啊有啊
Shure: No, there is.
Shure: 那我这样呢
Shure: What about like this?
Shure: 那就没有了
Shure: Then it's gone.
Jake:就是我觉得我好像一开始那个太阳
Jake: I feel like at the beginning, I was like the sun.
Shure: 行那我大概知道他这个玉指了
Shure: Alright, I think I get what he means by "jade finger."
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Shure: 这样是都有的对吧
Shure: So we've got everything, right?
Shure: OK
Jake:就是我一开始打的那个奶油
Jake: It's like the cream I whipped at the start.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:打出来的挺开心的好
Jake: I was pretty happy whipping it.
Jake:像也这样
Jake: Just like that.
Lucia: 哈哈没事
Lucia: Haha, it's fine.
Lucia: 他短暂的作为成品存在了一会对
Lucia: It existed as a finished product for a while, right?
Jake:啊存在过存在过
Jake: Yeah, it did exist.
Jake:妙
Jake: Wonderful.
Shure: 所以我们周一应该还有一天
Shure: So we should have one more day on Monday.
Shure: 周一晚上才能回去
Shure: We can only go back on Monday night.
Jake:这个这个挺好
Jake: This is great.
Lucia: 而且它作为成品的时候吧
Lucia: And when it was a finished product...
Shure: 周一要把要把要把这房子收了
Shure: We need to clean up this place on Monday.
Lucia: 它是一种传统艺术的蛋糕
Lucia: It's a cake that represents a traditional art form.
Alice:never let you go
Alice: never let you go
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 现在切完之后呢
Lucia: Now, after slicing it,
Lucia: 它成了一种当代艺术的蛋糕
Lucia: it has become a piece of contemporary art.
Shure: 你要不周一来帮忙吧
Shure: How about you come and help out on Monday?
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh
Lucia: 所以说实际上是一种审美上的进步
Lucia: So, it's actually an aesthetic improvement.
Jake:哈哈我去我去
Jake: Haha, I'll go, I'll go.
Shure: 周一是帮你
Shure: Monday is to help you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahaha
Shure: 周日不是过来吗
Shure: Weren't you coming over on Sunday?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 然后然后周一正好帮忙了
Shure: And then, you can help out on Monday.
Lucia: 嗯可能就是
Lucia: Well, maybe...
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Shure: 这是能说的是吗
Shure: Is this something we can talk about?
Lucia: 咨询界少了一个乱说PPT的人才
Lucia: The consulting world just lost someone who was great at making up stuff on PPTs.
Shure: 这是能听的吗哈哈哈
Shure: Can you even listen to this? Hahaha
Jake:呀
Jake: Ah
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 又要给你打黑弓是吗
Shure: Are you going to shoot the black arrow again?
Lucia: 哎现在盘子够了吗
Lucia: Hey, do we have enough plates now?
Jake:够了这个我吃
Jake: Yes, this one I'm eating.
Lucia: 够了这个我吃
Lucia: Yes, this one I'm eating.
Shure: 这什么东西
Shure: What is this?
Lucia: 哦居然够了
Lucia: Oh, it's actually enough.
Shure: 又要给你打黑工是吗
Jake:这样够了
Jake: This is enough.
Shure: 什么打黑工
Lucia: 嗯正好是我刚刚洗那盘
Lucia: Yeah, it's just the one I washed.
Shure: 嗯可不就是嘛
Shure: Yeah, isn't it?
Lucia: 要不我就用这个算了
Lucia: Or should I just use this one?
Shure: 你在对啥喝
Shure: 喝牛奶还是
Shure: Drinking milk or...
Katrina: can't buy me gum
Alice:can't buy me
Alice: can't buy me
Lucia: 感觉好像是
Lucia: It feels like it is.
Shure: 牛奶谢谢您
Shure: Milk, thank you.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure: 看着就香你看
Shure: Looks delicious, look.
Jake:看看我的嗜好
Jake: Look at my hobby.
Jake:确实不太高
Jake: It's really not that tall.
Katrina: young
Shure: 我跟你讲这里面真的全是刚切的水果
Shure: I'm telling you, it's all freshly cut fruit inside.
Jake:快长高啊
Jake: Grow taller quickly.
Alice:guy
Alice: guy
Shure: 蓝莓芒果草莓还有提子
Shure: Blueberries, mangoes, strawberries, and grapes.
Lucia: 没事时给他多挤点奶油
Lucia: No problem, just give him more cream.
Katrina: i need your love baby
Katrina: I need your love, baby.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 有没有忘了
Shure: Did you forget?
Jake:你弟弟
Jake: Your brother.
Shure: 提子好像直接吃了
Shure: The grapes seem to be eaten directly.
Katrina: i need your love
Katrina: I need your love.
Jake:你弟弟怎么长高啊
Jake: How is your brother going to grow taller?
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone.
Shure: 大家每天哈哈哈
Shure: Everyone, every day hahaha.
Jake:怎么长高啊
Jake: How do you grow taller?
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 每天每天买
Shure: Buy it every day.
Shure: 买这些水果
Shure: Buy these fruits.
Katrina: 蛋糕来喽
Katrina: Cake is here!
Shure: 本来都是准备什么给哪一天哪一天用
Shure: Originally, they were all prepared for specific days.
Lucia: 这个是咱们的是吧
Lucia: Is this ours?
Lucia: OK我把这就放
Lucia: Okay, I'll just place it here.
Shure: 结果洗吧洗吧都吃了你知道吗
Shure: In the end, we washed and ate them all, you know?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 现在是放下
Lucia: Now, put it down.
Lucia: 看看他们外面进度如何了
Lucia: Let's see how their progress is outside.
Katrina: 爱你需要勇敢的追
Katrina: Love needs to be bravely pursued.
Shure: 你看给爱
Shure: Look, give love.
Shure: 没幸福没你我怎么能幸福呢
Shure: No happiness, without you, how can I be happy?
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah, ah.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehe.
Jake:别哭
Jake: Don't cry.
Katrina: 如果你给的体会
Katrina: If you give the experience...
Jake:怎么了没事没事好嘞
Jake: What's wrong? It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 怎么了没事没事没事
Shure: What's wrong? It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 你好疯啊
Shure: You are crazy.
Shure: 我想扣电话你
Shure: I want to hang up on you.
Katrina: 依旧会回味
Katrina: Still savor the taste.
Shure: 你不会你舍不得的
Shure: You won't, you can't bear to.
Katrina: 除了爱我还一直以为
Katrina: Besides love, I always thought...
Shure: 咦嘿嘿
Shure: Ehehe.
Alice:太慢太慢了
Alice: Too slow, too slow.
Katrina: 一天一天
Katrina: Day by day.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Katrina: 看见i can't help but dreaming
Katrina: Seeing you, I can't help but dream.
Shure: 他不理我
Shure: He ignores me.
Katrina: i can't get enough
Katrina: I can't get enough.
Katrina: i need your love
Katrina: I need your love.
Shure: 杨老板怎么开始踱步了
Katrina: i need you girl
Katrina: I need you, girl.
Jake:为等饭吃
Jake: Waiting for the meal.
Katrina: i need you now coconut
Katrina: I need you now, coconut.
Shure: 饭大大厨
Shure: Chef, chef.
Shure: 大厨怎么样啊大厨
Shure: How's the chef doing, chef?
Alice:太慢了我感觉这炭火一会就烧完了
Alice: Too slow, I feel like this charcoal is going to burn out soon.
Shure: 大叔这鸡爪
Shure: Mister, these chicken feet...
Alice:哎呦哈哈哈哈
Alice: Oh my gosh, hahaha.
Katrina: my name i need you now
Katrina: My name, I need you now.
Katrina: oh god i trust
Katrina: Oh god, I trust.
Alice:我们是不是如果真的要考的话
Alice: If we really need to take the test...
Lucia: 我们是不是如果真的要考的话
Lucia: If we really need to take the test...
Lucia: 是不是他应该给我点
Lucia: Shouldn't he give me some...
Alice:是不是碳应该多点
Alice: Shouldn't there be more charcoal?
Alice:就整个的
Alice: Like, the whole thing.
Katrina: my heart
Katrina: My heart...
Shure: 整个全
Shure: The whole thing...
Shure: 铺满然后大概而且要要要铺高一点
Shure: Cover it completely, and it should be a bit higher.
Alice:对大概而且要要铺高一点对
Alice: Yes, cover it completely and a bit higher, yes.
Katrina: for many night gets through this dark
Katrina: For many nights, get through this dark.
Jake:好再打碎
Jake: Alright, smash it again.
Shure: 他离离得感觉有点远是吧
Shure: It feels like it's a bit far, right?
Jake:没电了
Jake: No power left.
Lucia: 认领一双筷子
Lucia: Claim a pair of chopsticks.
Shure: 是这样的吗
Shure: Is it like this?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 他离得是不是有点远啊
Shure: Is it a bit far?
Shure: 这个碳和肉之间的距离的话
Shure: The distance between the charcoal and the meat...
Alice:还行差别不大
Alice: It's fine, not much difference.
Shure: 还还是还行
Shure: It's still okay?
Shure: 是吗但反正最起码得铺满它是吧
Shure: Really? But at least it should be covered, right?
Jake:好餐前甜点
Jake: Alright, pre-meal dessert.
Alice:看也没有很多
Alice: Look, there isn't much.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No...
Shure: 你小子怎么就在这指挥让女孩干活呀
Shure: How come you're just directing and letting the girls do the work?
Alice:就是
Alice: Exactly.
Jake:餐前甜点吃
Jake: Eat the pre-meal dessert.
Shure: 来摆拍一下
Shure: Let's take a staged photo.
Shure: 摆拍一下
Shure: Take a staged photo.
Shure: 好吧其实一直我在干呢
Shure: Actually, I've been doing it all along.
Shure: 然后就是给你打打电话
Shure: And then I just called you.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 为什么只和你能聊一整夜
Katrina: Why can I only chat with you all night?
Shure: 之后就是嗯对是吧
Shure: So then, um, right?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
Jake:20%吧
Jake: Maybe 20%?
Katrina: 为什么才道别就当想见面
Katrina: Why are you already thinking about seeing each other again after just saying goodbye?
Jake:60%吧这么多啊好
Jake: Maybe 60%, that's a lot, okay.
Shure: 没有没有没有我也在
Shure: No, no, no, I'm here too.
Katrina: 在朋友里面就数你最特特别
Katrina: Among friends, you're the most unique.
Lucia: 味道还是很好的
Lucia: The taste is still really good.
Lucia: 嗯好棒
Lucia: Hmm, fantastic.
Jake:吃吗好吃
Jake: Want to eat? It's delicious.
Katrina: 总让我觉得记忆很甜
Katrina: Always makes my memories feel sweet.
Shure: 你知道我演这个炭演了多久吗
Shure: Do you know how long I've been playing this role?
Lucia: 特别好
Lucia: It's really good.
Katrina: 为什么你在意谁陪我逛街
Katrina: Why do you care who goes shopping with me?
Shure: 演了他妈将近一个小时你知道吗
Shure: I've been playing this role for almost an hour, you know?
Alice:演了他妈将近一个小时你知道吗
Alice: I've been playing this role for almost an hour, you know?
Jake:我们都干了什么呀
Jake: What did we do?
Jake:你在里面干了什么
Jake: What did you do in there?
Alice:才把这个炭整着
Alice: Just got this part done.
Shure: 才把这个炭整着
Shure: Just got this part done.
Jake:奶油奶油
Jake: Cream, cream.
Lucia: 打奶油
Lucia: Whipping cream.
Katrina: 为什么你担心谁对我疯癫
Katrina: Why are you worried about who goes crazy over me?
Shure: 本来7点多肉就演好了
Shure: The meat was done around 7 o'clock.
Alice:本来7点多肉就演好了
Alice: The meat was done around 7 o'clock.
Jake:哦就是最后刮的那个
Jake: Oh, it's the last one we scraped.
Alice:所以呢啊所以呢
Alice: So what now? So what now?
Shure: 所以呢啊所以呢
Shure: So what now? So what now?
Jake:嗯对基本上都是大概有OK
Jake: Uh, yeah, basically that's about it, okay.
Lucia: 对基本上都是打奶油
Lucia: Yeah, basically, it's all whipping cream.
Katrina: 你说你对我
Katrina: You said you're...
Alice:你现在不还在摸鱼
Alice: Aren't you slacking off now?
Shure: 你现在不还在摸鱼
Shure: Aren't you slacking off now?
Katrina: 多一些却又不说是多那一些
Katrina: A bit more, but not saying how much more.
Jake:我干了什么呀
Jake: What did I do?
Shure: 那不得摸一会吗
Shure: Shouldn't I slack off for a bit?
Jake:您干了多了去
Jake: You've done a lot.
Jake:哈哈哈我一开始打了那个
Jake: Hahaha, I started by whipping the cream.
Shure: 看我的室友们在干嘛
Shure: Let's see what my roommates are doing.
Jake:打了那是什么呀
Jake: What did you hit?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:就是让他起
Jake: Just get him up.
Shure: 打个招呼吧
Shure: Say hello.
Jake:呃怎么说呀
Jake: Uh, how do I say it?
Katrina: 哈喽
Katrina: Hello.
Jake:就是让他立起来
Jake: Just get him to stand up.
Katrina: 过两天就可以跟你见面了哈
Katrina: In a few days, you'll be able to meet me.
Jake:那是干嘛的啊
Jake: What's that for?
Lucia: 啊啊蛋糕胚
Lucia: Ah, cake base.
Jake:啊那是干嘛的呀蛋糕胚
Jake: Oh, what's the cake base for?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 你听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure: 我听到了
Shure: I heard it.
Shure: 每天都让你模拟大便
Shure: Making you simulate poop every day.
Shure: 好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 时间已经不多
Katrina: There's not much time left.
Katrina: 再下去只好只做朋友
Katrina: If we keep going, we'll just be friends.
Katrina: 再向前一点点我就会点头
Katrina: If you move a little closer, I'll nod.
Shure: 分身是吧
Shure: You're multitasking, right?
Katrina: 再冲动一点点我就不闪躲
Katrina: If you get a little more impulsive, I won't dodge.
Katrina: 不过三个字
Katrina: Just three words.
Shure: 怎么他小名也叫楠楠
Shure: Is his nickname also Nan Nan?
Jake:主要是欠了4层的功劳是吧
Jake: Mainly owes 4 levels of credit, right?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 他现在就是了
Shure: He is now.
Shure: 我不叫这个了
Shure: I don't go by that anymore.
Jake:我也觉得
Jake: I think so too.
Shure: 那你叫什么
Shure: What's your name then?
Shure: 叫北北是吗
Shure: Beibei, right?
Shure: 大草莓
Shure: Big strawberry.
Lucia: 我自己觉得超好吃
Lucia: I think it's super delicious.
Shure: 嗯他是黄
Shure: Hmm, it's yellow.
Jake:嗯奶油好吃
Jake: Hmm, the cream is delicious.
Shure: 不是他是黄油
Shure: No, it's butter.
Lucia: 谢谢老师夸奖哈哈哈
Lucia: Thank you for the compliment, teacher, hahaha.
Katrina: 为什么我的过去很容易安慰我们
Katrina: Why is my past so easy to comfort us?
Shure: 他是奶油
Shure: It's cream.
Shure: 跟咱俩那天买的那个是一样的
Shure: It's the same as the one we bought the other day.
Katrina: 心里面明明都有感觉
Katrina: We both have that feeling in our hearts.
Alice:熟了吗
Alice: Is it done?
Lucia: 咱俩是不是得给老师点精神损失费啊
Lucia: Should we compensate the teacher for emotional damages?
Lucia: 你说哈哈哈哈
Lucia: What do you think, hahaha.
Shure: 就是那个带黄油味的那个
Shure: It's the one with the butter flavor.
Katrina: 为什么不分辨
Katrina: Why not distinguish?
Jake:老师我给你烤肉去好吧
Jake: Teacher, I'll grill some meat for you, alright?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 为什么你寂寞只想要我陪
Katrina: Why do you only want me to accompany you when you're lonely?
Shure: 那个奶油
Shure: That cream.
Shure: 不是啊那个奶油是个海盐的吧
Shure: No, that cream was sea salt flavored, right?
Jake:老师你要吃什么肉
Jake: Teacher, what kind of meat do you want?
Lucia: 儿子你要吃什么肉
Lucia: Son, what kind of meat do you want?
Katrina: 为什么我难过只肯让你安慰
Katrina: Why do you only let me comfort you when you're sad?
Shure: 啊对海盐的那个
Shure: Ah, right, the sea salt one.
Katrina: 我们心里面明明都有感觉
Katrina: We both have that feeling in our hearts.
Alice:好像瘦了吧
Alice: Seems like you've lost weight.
Katrina: 为什么不敢面对
Katrina: Why don't you dare to face it?
Shure: 沉浸式给你表演吃饭
Shure: Immersively showing you how I eat.
Katrina: 友达以上恋人未满
Katrina: More than friends, less than lovers.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 甜蜜心酸愉悦混乱
Katrina: Sweet, bitter, joyful, chaotic.
Katrina: 我们以后会变怎样
Katrina: What will we become in the future?
Katrina: 我迫不及待想知道答案
Katrina: I'm eagerly waiting to know the answer.
Shure: 认识四年了头一回打视频是吧
Shure: We've known each other for four years, first time video chatting, right?
Katrina: 再靠近一点就让你牵手
Katrina: Get a little closer, and I'll let you hold my hand.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈不是吧差不多
Shure: Hahaha, isn't it? Almost.
Katrina: 再勇敢一点点我就跟你走
Katrina: Be a little braver, and I'll go with you.
Lucia: 嗯很棒很棒
Lucia: Hmm, great, great.
Shure: 只不过上次跟你打视频的时候
Shure: Just last time when I video chatted with you.
Katrina: 你还等什么时间已经不多
Katrina: What are you waiting for? Time is running out.
Jake:很棒很棒
Jake: Great, great.
Shure: 我也在跟我群友打视频而已啦嗯
Shure: I was just video chatting with my group friends too, hmm.
Lucia: 开心
Lucia: Happy.
Jake:接下来就是下一个
Jake: Next up is the next one.
Katrina: 再下去只好只做朋友
Katrina: If it goes on, we can only be friends.
Katrina: 再向前一点点我就会点头
Katrina: Move a little forward, and I'll nod my head.
Alice:虾仁盘子可以拿过来了
Alice: The shrimp plate can be brought over.
Shure: 大一的时候都没打过是吧
Shure: You didn't whip it in your first year, right?
Jake:是不是要再打一次
Jake: Should we whip it again?
Lucia: 是不是要再打一些
Lucia: Should we whip some more?
Shure: 好像是吧
Shure: Seems like it, yeah.
Jake:对淡奶油要再打一次
Jake: Yeah, we need to whip the cream again.
Jake:那个盆就不用洗了
Jake: No need to wash that bowl.
Shure: 以后不要不要羞涩跟你讲
Shure: Don't be shy next time, okay?
Shure: 不要像现在那么不要脸
Shure: Don't be shameless like now.
Jake:嗯反正都打奶油好嘞
Jake: Yeah, anyway, we need to whip the cream again.
Lucia: 哦那行
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈啊
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Alice:应该都熟了
Alice: It should all be cooked by now.
Lucia: 然后还是称
Lucia: And then we still measure.
Shure: 你是在说你自己吗
Shure: Are you talking about yourself?
Shure: 是的那不然呢
Shure: Yes, of course.
Alice:把它们叫出来
Alice: Bring them out.
Lucia: 直接把盆放电子秤上
Lucia: Just put the bowl on the electronic scale.
Alice:可以吃了
Alice: We can eat now.
Shure: 真好意思真好意思
Shure: Really shameless, really shameless.
Alice:每个人分一点点吧
Alice: Everyone take a little bit.
Shure: 真羞涩那
Shure: Really shy then.
Shure: 时候怎么了
Shure: What happened then?
Shure: 那时候不羞涩吗
Shure: Weren't you shy back then?
Shure: 你不要做那青蛙表情
Shure: Don't make that frog face.
Katrina: 尝两口然后端进去
Katrina: Try a couple of bites and then take it inside.
Lucia: 你觉这个奶油甜度刚刚好吗
Lucia: Do you think the cream's sweetness is just right?
Jake:觉得这个奶油甜度刚刚好啊
Jake: I think the cream's sweetness is just right.
Katrina: 你已经在吃蛋糕了
Katrina: You are already eating the cake.
Lucia: 我觉得可以
Lucia: I think it's good.
Lucia: 那这样的话就还是按1:10的比例
Lucia: So let's keep the 1:10 ratio.
Shure: 你可以把它剪一下吗
Shure: Can you cut it?
Shure: 就是把这个大的剪刀剪
Shure: Just use the big scissors.
Lucia: 你觉得呢
Lucia: What do you think?
Katrina: 剪刀在哪呀
Katrina: Where are the scissors?
Lucia: 因为其实我还蛮爱吃甜的
Lucia: Actually, I really love sweets.
Shure: 那不用的了
Shure: No need then.
Katrina: 这要洗一下不
Katrina: Do we need to wash this?
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 所以对我来说我觉得是刚好OK的
Lucia: So for me, I think it's just right.
Shure: 是一直捡手肉的
Shure: He's always picking up the meat by hand.
Shure: 我帮你我帮你夹一下来
Shure: Let me help you, I'll hold it for you.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哦那是那个生蚝他们还没烤呢
Lucia: Oh, those are the oysters, they haven't grilled them yet.
Shure: 他其实应该再剪碎一点
Shure: He should actually chop it finer.
Katrina: 还要剪碎一点
Katrina: Needs to be chopped finer.
Shure: 你哎没事挺好挺好
Shure: You, hey, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 嗯准备出去了吗
Lucia: Hmm, are you ready to go out?
Shure: 这个这个再见
Shure: This, this, goodbye.
Alice:哒哒哒哒
Alice: Da-da-da-da.
Katrina: 呀呀
Katrina: Ya-ya.
Shure: 你从你先从底下剪然后这样
Shure: You start cutting from the bottom, then like this.
Lucia: 灯怎么灭了
Lucia: Why did the light go out?
Shure: 我不就一可以一直可以夹着吗
Shure: I can just keep holding it, right?
Katrina: 呀
Katrina: Ya.
Shure: 学废了吗
Jake:我来拿点肉过来
Jake: I'll go get some meat.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Alice:你们可以先吃一点点
Alice: You guys can start eating a little bit.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 你在看什么
Shure: What are you looking at?
Jake:吃什么
Jake: What to eat?
Alice:在那个盘里
Alice: In that plate.
Alice:我夹过去了
Alice: I moved it over.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 哦好的
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Alice:杨老板你是不是饿了
Alice: Jake, are you hungry?
Lucia: 你就把这个先拿下来啊
Lucia: Just take this down first.
Jake:呃呃还行还行
Jake: Uh, uh, I'm okay.
Lucia: 但是那我怎么知道20颗糖
Lucia: But how will I know it's 20 candies?
Jake:好了我来领
Jake: Alright, I'm coming.
Jake:有多的碗吗
Jake: Are there extra bowls?
Jake:没有好的好的
Jake: No? Alright, alright.
Katrina: 没有直接上筷子吧
Katrina: No, just use the chopsticks directly.
Shure: 就每天带着这眼镜不敢摘
Shure: I wear these glasses every day, don't dare to take them off.
Shure: 摘了就像裸奔一样
Shure: Taking them off feels like streaking.
Shure: 哦今天洗脸的时候你知道吗
Shure: Oh, today when I was washing my face, you know...
Katrina: 那个就是眼睛能看清自己
Katrina: That's when you can see yourself clearly.
Shure: 那个就是眼睛能看清
Shure: That's when you can see clearly.
Jake:给你们夹肉
Jake: Let me get you some meat.
Shure: 就以为自己还戴着眼镜
Shure: Thought I was still wearing glasses.
Katrina: 以为自己还戴着眼镜
Katrina: Thought I was still wearing glasses.
Katrina: 然后就手下意识这样一戴
Katrina: Then instinctively went to adjust them.
Shure: 然后就手下意识这样一下
Shure: Then instinctively did this gesture.
Jake:整个盘子吧
Jake: The whole plate, maybe?
Katrina: 结果发现什么都没抓到
Katrina: But realized I grabbed nothing.
Shure: 结果发现什么都没抓到
Shure: But realized I grabbed nothing.
Katrina: 抓到空处
Katrina: Grabbed air.
Shure: 抓到空气
Shure: Grabbed air.
Lucia: 刚不是有个盘子好像
Lucia: Wasn't there a plate just now?
Jake:这这3个盘子是
Jake: These three plates are...
Shure: 就特不适应
Shure: It's really uncomfortable.
Lucia: 呃那个盘
Lucia: Uh, that plate...
Lucia: 那那几盘还要冲一下
Lucia: Those plates need to be rinsed.
Lucia: 就是我刚拿下来本来要放蛋糕的
Lucia: I took them down to put the cake on.
Jake:好冲一冲
Jake: Okay, rinse them.
Lucia: 但后来够了然后就没没再管他
Lucia: But later, I had enough, so I didn't bother anymore.
Shure: 但是你戴着隐形眼镜洗脸的话
Shure: But if you wash your face with contact lenses on...
Jake:好那个串
Jake: Okay, the skewers...
Katrina: 隐形眼镜洗脸的话它不会进水吗
Katrina: Won't the contact lenses get wet?
Shure: 它不会进水吗
Shure: Won't they get wet?
Lucia: 这里还有个串
Lucia: There's another skewer here.
Katrina: 或者就是手碰到眼睛特难受
Katrina: Or if your hand touches your eyes, it's really uncomfortable.
Shure: 或者就是手碰到眼睛不会难受吗
Shure: Or if your hand touches your eyes, won't it be uncomfortable?
Shure: 嗯不会
Shure: Hmm, it won't.
Shure: 你知道我每天都怎么带吗
Shure: Do you know how I wear them every day?
Shure: 我就是纯对着空气
Shure: I just aim into the air.
Jake:这叫啥名字来着
Jake: What's this called again?
Shure: 然后拿拿着一只手指头
Shure: Then I hold out a finger.
Shure: 然后粘起来一个
Shure: Then I stick it in.
Alice:怎么这么多筷子呀
Alice: Why are there so many chopsticks?
Jake:就就叫这个
Jake: Just call it this.
Shure: 然后卡对着眼睛开始出
Shure: Then I align it with my eye and start inserting.
Jake:嗯好的对
Jake: Uh, okay, yes.
Alice:咦这怎么有蛋糕啊
Alice: Hey, why is there cake here?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:叫纸杯戚风
Jake: It's called paper cup chiffon.
Shure: 忘跟大叔说了
Shure: Forgot to tell the uncle.
Jake:爆浆巧克力蛋糕
Jake: Molten chocolate cake.
Shure: 蛋糕上了
Shure: The cake is ready.
Alice:谢谢尝一块
Alice: Thanks, I'll try a piece.
Jake:戚风是什么意思
Jake: What does chiffon mean?
Shure: 开早开早
Shure: Start early, start early.
Jake:戚风是指很蓬松的意思
Jake: Chiffon means very fluffy.
Shure: 我感觉这个比刚刚那个味味好了一些
Shure: I think this one tastes better than the last one.
Alice:你腌的时间长吗
Alice: Did you marinate it for a long time?
Shure: 就是而且我后来又加了很多
Shure: Yeah, and I added a lot more.
Shure: 有很多那个料
Shure: Added a lot of seasoning.
Alice:关这咋吃
Alice: How do we eat this?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈好的
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:给他独特的风味
Jake: It gives it a unique flavor.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:在哪吃
Alice: Where do we eat it?
Shure: 拿拿筷子直接吃吧
Shure: Just grab some chopsticks and eat it.
Shure: 别别这别上手了吧
Shure: No, no, don't use your hands.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:来拿脸走
Jake: Come, bring your face over.
Shure: 这都都都拿走吧大厨
Shure: Let's take everything away, Chef.
Jake:拿脸进去
Jake: Bring your face in.
Lucia: 哎咱垃圾垃圾桶是都拿过来一下吗
Lucia: Hey, should we bring the trash can over?
Jake:怎么能都拿走啊
Jake: How can we take everything away?
Jake:不能都拿走
Jake: We can't take it all away.
Shure: 基本人都在里面吧
Shure: Most people are inside, right?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 天呐我灯还亮着吗你帮
Katrina: Oh my, is my light still on? Can you help?
Lucia: 你去外面溜达一圈
Lucia: Go take a walk outside.
Jake:亮着很亮
Jake: Yes, it's on, very bright.
Jake:哦你们都来了
Jake: Oh, you're all here.
Jake:好那吃吧
Jake: Alright, let's eat.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Shure: 我又给AI数据集贡献了一些
Shure: I've contributed some more to the AI dataset.
Katrina: 看
Katrina: Look...
Shure: 人类在远程沟通了一些方式
Shure: Humans have developed some ways of remote communication.
Katrina: 一下
Katrina: One sec...
Shure: 真的我觉得应该跟你在这看色之前
Shure: Really, I think I should look at the color before...
Katrina: 孜然粉就是在里面
Katrina: The cumin powder is in there.
Shure: 每天远程当我的数据集
Shure: Every day, remotely, as part of my dataset.
Lucia: 我觉得我其实已经不太用得到筷子了
Lucia: I feel like I don't really need chopsticks anymore.
Shure: 那天
Shure: That day...
Shure: 那天线下的
Shure: That offline day...
Katrina: 孜然粉
Katrina: Cumin powder.
Alice:哎呀好东西
Alice: Oh, that's good stuff.
Shure: 你看我你还嫌我话多
Shure: You think I talk too much.
Shure: 嗯好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 不说了行了吧
Shure: I'll stop talking, alright?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 他为什么会有突然有个大拇指的标志
Shure: Why did he suddenly have a thumbs-up sign?
Lucia: a
Lucia: Uh.
Shure: 是这个能能能
Shure: Is this... this... this...
Lucia: 加一
Lucia: Plus one.
Lucia: 你想喝牛奶还是小青柠
Lucia: Do you want milk or lime soda?
Shure: 出什么效果吗之类的
Shure: Does it have any special effects or something?
Lucia: 我都可以
Lucia: I'm good with either.
Shure: 不知道不知道不知道
Shure: I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
Lucia: 我们那外面好像给大家都倒了
Lucia: I think they poured some for everyone outside.
Lucia: 那个小青
Lucia: That lime soda.
Shure: 我我只知道那个
Shure: I only know that...
Lucia: 你喝吗我不喝那我们
Lucia: Are you drinking it? I'm not, so...
Shure: 苹果的电脑
Shure: Apple computer.
Shure: 可以在通话的时候加这种东西
Shure: You can add these things during calls.
Jake:喝什么
Jake: What are you drinking?
Shure: 但是手机和iPad我也不知道
Shure: But on phones and iPads, I don't know.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Shure: 哦这其实是加了的
Shure: Oh, this is actually added.
Jake:好喝
Jake: Tastes good.
Shure: 有那个回应
Shure: It has that response.
Shure: 他可能看不见我感觉
Shure: He might not see me, I think.
Jake:还缺筷子吗
Jake: Do we still need more chopsticks?
Jake:外面可能是
Jake: Maybe outside...
Lucia: 外面应该不缺
Lucia: Outside should be enough.
Jake:应该不存
Jake: Shouldn't be missing.
Lucia: 因为我在外面放了6双
Lucia: Because I put six pairs outside.
Jake:我在外面放了路上
Jake: I put some on the way.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, good.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 可以先看一眼
Lucia: We can take a quick look first.
Shure: 放出来了
Shure: It's out.
Jake:砍一下
Jake: Cut it.
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Shure: 这这样可以吗
Shure: Is this okay?
Shure: 这样可以吗
Shure: 哈哈哈他给我标过数据吗
Shure: Hahaha, did he mark the data for me?
Jake:海
Jake: Hi.
Jake:他给我标过数据吗
Jake: Did he mark the data for me?
Jake:他没给你标好的
Jake: He didn't mark it for you.
Shure: 他没给你标过数据
Shure: He didn't mark the data for you.
Shure: 他他
Shure: He, he...
Shure: 到时候可以来帮标数据
Shure: He can come and help mark the data later.
Katrina: 嗯好香啊
Katrina: Hmm, it smells so good.
Shure: 就是给给给这几天录的东西打标签
Shure: Just tagging the stuff we've recorded these days.
Katrina: 小蛋糕
Katrina: Little cake.
Jake:唉有吗柠檬
Jake: Hey, is there any lemon?
Shure: 到时候需要
Shure: We'll need it later.
Lucia: 什么柠檬
Lucia: What lemon?
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Lucia: 放了一点应该
Lucia: Put a bit, I guess.
Jake:噢对一开始给了一点
Jake: Oh right, added some at the beginning.
Shure: 大概打哪是什么
Shure: Around where, what's this?
Shure: 哪是什么哪是什么这种的标签吧
Shure: Like, tagging stuff like this.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 等会让我再吃两口再回去打
Lucia: Let me take a few more bites before going back to tag.
Shure: 智力低下的那种
Shure: Mentally challenged type.
Lucia: 还像刚打到刚才那种程度好了
Lucia: Just like the level we just had.
Shure: 他像刚才那种滚
Shure: Like, just roll like before.
Shure: 哈哈你倒是可以打
Shure: Haha, you can tag it.
Shure: 然后就是到我这个人的轮廓的时候
Shure: And then when it comes to my outline.
Jake:这些筷子我就洗一下用生的
Jake: I'll just wash these chopsticks and use them raw.
Shure: 人家都打human
Shure: People tag "human".
Shure: 然后到我这打那个智力低下怎么说
Shure: But for me, how do you tag "mentally challenged"?
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Jake:这些都是生的是吧
Jake: These are all raw, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:哦那我还是拿几个出来
Jake: Oh, I'll just take a few out.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 这这是手
Katrina: This, this is hand.
Katrina: 这可以用
Katrina: This can be used.
Jake:这个是新的
Jake: This one is new.
Katrina: 这干净
Katrina: It's clean.
Jake:那你们领
Jake: Then you guys take it.
Jake:你们拿一个
Jake: You guys take one.
Jake:我还是吸两个
Jake: I'll take two.
Jake:吸两双出来
Jake: I'll take out two pairs.
Jake:你们领一双吧
Jake: You guys take one pair.
Katrina: 的
Katrina: Got it.
Jake:我再拧三双吧
Jake: I'll take three pairs.
Jake:那他克星也有
Jake: Then he also has one.
Lucia: 也行我把这个先放回去然后
Lucia: Okay, I'll put this back first and then...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 还好有点主食
Shure: Luckily we have some main dishes.
Lucia: 咱筷子还够吗
Lucia: Do we have enough chopsticks?
Shure: 不然的话这肉等到现在都他妈饿死了
Shure: Otherwise, we'd be starving waiting for the meat.
Jake:够够够够
Jake: We have enough, enough.
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Lucia: 我要不把这双直接洗了算了
Lucia: Why don't I just wash this pair directly?
Lucia: 嗯那也行那我现在
Lucia: Hmm, okay, then I'll...
Jake:一起我一起写
Jake: Let's do it together, I'll write it down.
Jake:你来打哎
Jake: You go hit it.
Lucia: 那我也回去打奶油了
Lucia: Then I'll go back and whip the cream.
Shure: 你要胃疼的话你要不先吃点药吧
Shure: If you have a stomachache, maybe you should take some medicine first.
Jake:对对对你
Jake: Yeah, yeah, you...
Jake:你给师傅服务去
Jake: Go serve the master.
Lucia: 给谁服务师傅
Lucia: Serve who? The master?
Jake:师傅
Jake: The master.
Shure: 你说话能不能别带妈
Shure: Can you not swear when you talk?
Jake:嗯大师
Jake: Hmm, the master.
Shure: 你平时带的少了是吗
Shure: Do you not swear enough usually?
Jake:那我可不能吃
Jake: I can't eat that.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 不带啊哦
Shure: Don't swear, oh.
Shure: 好好好怎么
Shure: Okay, okay, how...
Shure: 今天为回家
Shure: Are you going home today?
Shure: 开始规规范自己的说话了是吗
Shure: Are you starting to regulate your speech?
Jake:怎么洗呀
Jake: How to wash it?
Jake:洗
Jake: Wash it.
Shure: 没有啊不需要规范
Shure: No, you don't need to regulate it.
Shure: 我平时就这个样子
Shure: I'm usually like this.
Jake:刚拿出来
Jake: Just took it out.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 打下地起就开始去
Shure: Started from the ground up, then began to go.
Jake:刚拆封的
Jake: Just unsealed it.
Jake:刚拿出来哦
Jake: Just took it out, oh.
Shure: 文明的好孩子是吧
Shure: A good civilized kid, right?
Shure: 我一直是啊
Shure: I always am.
Jake:哎别
Jake: Hey, don't.
Shure: 那聊天记录刚刚那条傻逼
Shure: Then that chat record, the idiot from just now.
Shure: 是谁发的
Shure: Who sent it?
Lucia: 不用叠一起吧
Lucia: No need to stack them together, right?
Lucia: 好像有一个盘子是我刚才用的
Lucia: Seems like one of the plates is the one I just used.
Lucia: 没事叠一起也行
Lucia: It's okay, you can stack them.
Lucia: 无所谓了
Lucia: Doesn't matter.
Katrina: 我来烤一会吧
Katrina: Let me grill for a while.
Katrina: 你去休息一会
Katrina: You go take a break.
Katrina: 吃个小蛋糕啥的
Katrina: Have a little cake or something.
Shure: 杨老板是不是都快饿坏了
Shure: Jake must be starving by now.
Alice:没事我不吃蛋糕太甜了
Alice: It's okay, I don't eat cake, too sweet.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 哇这个好像真的要烤好久
Katrina: Wow, this really seems like it's going to take a while to grill.